well good morning everyone
nice to see everyone here on this
beautiful day good morning
i'm tim lewis the member of parliament
for kitchener conestoga and before we
start i just want to acknowledge that uh
we're on the traditional territory of
the anushnabi the haudenosaunee and the
neutral people
um and also want to acknowledge uh some
special guests the mayor of kitchener is
worship barry verbanovic and also mp
brian may from cambridge is here valerie
bradford member of parliament from
kitchener south hespeler and the
honorable waters chagger member
prominent from waterloo i'll introduce
my special guest next um
just put a few notes here
the prime minister and i just uh
just sat down with some neighbors at a
kitchen table gathered at a kitchen
table neighbors that i know but you can
always get to know better
and
the kitchen table is where so many of
those discussions happen it's where it's
where big ideas start it's where the
little day-to-day decisions are made
it's where our kids tell us what's going
on in their lives it's where we invite
our friends and family over to share
ideas
uh it's where messes are made but where
they're also cleaned up and it's where
disagreements happen
but they're worked out
and so
it's such an honor to be in the country
that at the kitchen table
the prime minister and i can sit down
with neighbors
who i know
and get to know them a little bit better
so i'm very very honored that you were
here today and and fortunate that's a
it's a very canadian story so so ladies
and gentlemen uh the prime minister of
canada the right honorable justin
trudeau
thank you so much tim for your your warm
words but thank you also for your great
work here as as mp
i want to thank as well our colleagues
from the region uh bardish valerie and
brian
and also highlight barry's presence uh
mayor irbanovic it's great to see you
again we've worked together for many
many years i'm glad to have you
as part of this announcement because it
really is important that all orders of
government work together in constructive
ways i think we've managed to
demonstrate that over the past years
many many times in many ways but there's
a lot more to do as always and that was
something we talked about when i sat
down with sean and carolyn
and ian and elene and their kids to talk
about the challenges they're facing as
as communities obviously um
sean and carolyn have a beautiful home
here that they bought a number of years
ago but there's a recognition that as
families look to get into the housing
market right now it's getting more and
more difficult and even as families save
up
and work hard
every passing year seems to get housing
further and further away from them and
that's
one of the big challenges around
affordability that we're focused on with
budget 2022 and that's
very much what uh what i want to talk
about today
we know uh that housing is a real
challenge not just here in kitchener but
right across the country and that's
where
we need to work together to solve we
need to work together different orders
of government we need to make sure we're
there to support families because
getting a house into a home building a
strong future
for yourselves for your kids
should be something accessible to all
families across this country and
more and more it's just not but we also
know it's a complex problem without
having any one simple solution and
that's why we're moving forward and have
been over the past years with many
different programs and approaches
that are tailored to meet different
needs across the country in budget 2022
we're focused on three main
uh
we're focused on three pillars
supply
savings and cutting down on speculation
around supply we're going to work as we
have been with partners like in
municipalities to move forward on the
housing accelerator fund what this is is
4 billion dollars
designed
to help cities and towns right across
the country increase the supply of
housing whether it's issues around
permits or zoning whether it's
land use studies
whether it's just accelerating
incentives for
construction these are the kinds of
things we're going to be working on with
the cities because we know we need to
double
the new housing starts in this country
over the next 10 years and that's what
this plan is going to do we're also
going to continue with an extremely
successful program called the rapid
housing initiative that has uh allowed
for thousands upon thousands of new
homes and new uh new uh uh properties to
be built over the the past couple of
years uh that will allow for thousands
more
in some of the pressures that families
are facing
we're also going to support with savings
and the big vehicle for that in budget
2022 is a 40 000
uh tax-free savings account for the
purchase of a first home and this
account is tax-free on the way in and
tax-free on the way out as you buy your
first home so this is going to help
incentivize and support families as they
save up for that first down payment
there's also other measures we've put in
over the years that'll be there to help
people save but we know that saving up
for that first home is really important
the third pillar is recognizing that
even
if there's a house there even if you've
saved up for it
there are unfair practices in
the real estate market that we need to
push back on first of all far too many
homes in this country are being bought
by foreign investors looking at housing
as an asset class as opposed to a place
to raise a family and that's something
we need to crack down on so we're going
to ban foreign buyers
in homes for the next two years to make
sure that canadians have an opportunity
to buy their homes and not see homes
prices driven up as asset classes
other thing we're going to do is make
sure we're standing up for home buyers
the home buyers bill of right
and a crackdown on
unfair practices like blind bidding and
others that just make it so difficult
and and heart wrenching as people are
trying to fight and find their first
home
these are all measures that are
concretely moved forward over the coming
years in easing the pressures on
families and giving people an
opportunity to be confident not just
about their future but about their kids
future as well and that's something we
talked about a lot as we were talking
about climate change we're talking about
the various pressures on families the
challenges of inflation the cost of
living while at the same time
looking at how lucky we are in canada uh
that we were there for each other as
much as we were through this pandemic as
we come out of it we have an opportunity
uh to build stronger more resilient
communities and that's exactly what
we're focused on with budget 2022 and
speaking of working together very happy
now to pass it over to my friend mira
banovic for his
his words thank you barry for everything
you do
thank you very much mr prime minister
and it's a real pleasure to welcome you
back here to waterloo region and to the
city of kitchener again uh today uh and
i do want to acknowledge that chair
redmond would very much like to have
been here but unfortunately wasn't able
to rearrange her schedule
ahead of today's meeting
i'm really pleased to welcome you back
here we've had you here for for on many
other occasions we've had you here for
the keg tapping of oktoberfest we've had
you here at communitech and at vidyard
and at google at different points in
time
but today we're here for something that
really matters to kitchener residents
from across all walks of life in fact
for canadians from coast to coast to
coast and that's the issue of affordable
housing along the full housing uh
continuum but before i talk about that i
really want to just give a shout out to
to your team the government mps
who are here with you brian may bartis
chagger
valerie bradford and of course the host
mp tim tim lewis prime minister our area
could not be uh better represented by a
wonderful team and over the past couple
of years the support that municipalities
like kitchener and the region of
waterloo have had uh with covet 19 the
safe restart funding and so on has been
extremely important and i really just
want to say the team here have been rock
stars and thank you to to you and all of
them
but can just maybe say a few words about
the relationship that cities like
kitchener and the region of waterloo
have had with the government of canada
over the past number of years uh
together with the federation of canadian
municipalities we've been able to
achieve a great deal in fact it was in
your first term as prime minister that
we were able to deli that the government
was able to deliver on the national
housing strategy something that cities
like kitchener were calling for for many
years
and and in addition to that we were also
calling for a program like the rapid
housing initiative and sure enough in
the second term the shared goal of the
rapid housing initiative focused around
eliminating homelessness over a number
of years uh was a program that your
government listened to cities about and
in fact
created the program and created
thousands of units across canada
this initiative is in fact changing
lives in the city of kitchener and
throughout waterloo region
just a couple of examples
for example indigenous families and
individuals moving into 30 units
that are being built by the kw urban
native wigwam project in cambridge and
we'll see women moving into over 40
units at the yw partnership in the city
of kitchener that's happening all of
this is happening through the rapid
housing initiative
budget 2022 once again listen to the
voices of cities and communities and
we're very appreciative as cities of the
many investments that the federal
government has made
with respect to
housing and as cities and communities
we're ready to roll up our sleeves in
order to get that money flowing and
making a difference in the lives of
of peoples in our community so when the
next phase of rapid housing initiative
funding starts flowing we'll be ready as
we were in the first two phases to get
those units built and we're certainly
ready to work together with the federal
government and the four billion dollars
in the federal housing accelerator fund
with the goal of building a hundred
thousand new units in the next five
years
prime minister you were absolutely right
when you said canada and canadians are
best served when the orders of
government work together on behalf of
canadians i think we've demonstrated
that over the last number of years and i
can tell you as one city in one region
i'm ready with my colleagues to roll up
our sleeves in the cities townships in
the region here to uh to work together
with you and make make a difference for
our future and i'll turn it back to you
[Applause]
thank you we now have time for questions
from the media
media
we have one question one follow-up for
each reporter please identify your
outlet and your name thank you we can
start with the first question
hi this is hala with cbc
i'm just wondering well the heavy
artillery you announced yesterday come
from the canadian army inventory will
you provide ammunition and will that be
guided ammunition as well and when will
you commit to replace these and other
weapons taken from canadian inventories
in english and french please
from the very beginning of russia's
illegal invasion of ukraine and indeed
uh in in the weeks before
we've been there for ukraine we've been
sending
lethal and non-lethal military
assistance we've been there for
humanitarian support significant
financial support for the people in the
government of ukraine as well as
they deal with this unconscionable
illegal invasion by uh by russia
we have every step of the way responded
to
the requests and the specific asks of
the ukrainian government of president
zielinski who i speak with whom i speak
regularly and their most recent ask was
exactly for that for heavy artillery
for
reasons of operational security i can't
go into the details uh at this point on
uh how and what we're getting to them
exactly but i can assure you we will
have more to say in the coming days as
we deliver what they actually need to be
able to continue not just to defend
their own homeland against this illegal
russian invasion but to defend the very
values and principles that we hold dear
in canada and around the world as free
and open democracies
[Music]
[Music]
and just a quick follow-up
do you have any idea when these weapons
or others taken from canadian
inventories will be replaced
the ability of canada to contribute
fully to nato is one that is extremely
important for us
and every step of the way as we support
ukraine including with military
equipment and munitions
we are also making sure that canada
continues to have the capacity to
operate not just to defend canada but to
participate fully in nato operations as
well
okay next question
my prime minister i'm stephanie with ctv
kitchener
um so russia has claimed that there are
canadians fighting in mariupol right now
is the canadian government aware of any
canadians fighting for ukraine there and
will there be any assistance given if
they are captured
we know uh that canadians feel very
strongly about supporting people in
ukraine uh across the country people
have been opening up their homes their
communities uh to
support ukrainians either fleeing war or
supporting them through donations and
through delivery of of
of equipment and supports
we also know that a number of canadians
have chosen to go and fight
alongside ukrainians either because of
their own ukrainian heritage or because
they want to help stand up for democracy
against this illegal russian uh invasion
uh there are no active uh you know
forces being deployed uh by canada in
ukraine obviously but there are
certainly individual citizens who've
chosen uh to contribute
we will always be there to try and help
canadians but what we said from the very
beginning was canadians
should be leaving ukraine uh because
we're going to be very limited in our
capacity to help them uh if things go
wrong
follow-up yeah it's uh similar to the
question that my friend just asked you
but
a member of the ukrainian parliament
tweeted this morning saying they're now
starting to receive delivery of heavy
artillery from western countries when
should canadians expect that the heavy
artillery canada ascending to a rise in
ukraine i think people understand that
delivery of military equipment
in the
context of an illegal war by russia is
something that we have to be a little
bit
careful about what we broadcast and
publicize and what we're doing uh but in
the coming days i certainly hope to be
able to share more about what is being
sent what was sent
but i can reassure canadians that we are
directly responding to the top requests
that the ukrainians have given for
assistance
in this current phase of the war which
is uh a redoubled efforts by uh russia
uh to take uh take donbass and therefore
there is very specific equipment that
ukrainians may need and canadians can be
comfortable that their government is
there to support ukrainians with what
they need next question
good morning prime minister jeff out
from the waterloo region record i want
to return to housing for a second here
my son 25 years old still lives at home
with us college grad good paying job
he laughs off the idea that he'll ever
own a house a detached house like the
one he lives in now that we were able to
afford 25 years ago he just thinks it's
a joke the housing prices are ridiculous
there's no way he's ever going to be
able to afford the kind of mortgage it
would take crippling for life
so i want to ask your thoughts on that
those uh you know people starting out in
their 20s and early 30s uh what do you
say to them do you say give up on
detached ownership and go for something
smaller and it's a dream that's dead
you're never going to get there let me
ask how do you feel about it uh
obviously i've heard from uh canadians
like your son uh across the country who
are really worried about the housing
market who wonder whether or not they'll
ever be able to afford a home one of the
challenges we're facing in canada is our
population with immigration and other
things has been growing over the past
years and housing construction hasn't
kept up
which
is a real problem and that's why one of
the initiatives we're working on four
billion dollars towards municipalities
in order to double the construction of
new housing over the coming years
this is something that is going to help
uh whether it's enough or directly going
to be helping your son we'll have to see
because there's not just one program
that's going to help anyone there's
going to be a range of programs from
programs of renting to own that we've
launched as well in this budget from
programs that are helping the first time
home buyers with increased incentives
and reduction in their more mortgage
costs
initiatives to build greater density
particularly around public transit that
are going to allow people to get into
the housing market with their first
starter condo starter home these are the
kinds of things that get people's toes
in the door
we know that young people need to be
able to
build the stable base with which they
want to start a family give their future
kids the kinds of opportunities that
their parents worked hard to give them
and that's what this budget and this
focus of the government is on right now
but it's not going to be easy
it's going to take a number of years and
anyone who's promising that they have a
quick fix for it
is not being straight with canadians
it's going to take all of us working
together to curb foreign speculation to
make sure that market is fairer to
create more housing units and offer and
to support families being able to save
up to do that and that's very much what
we're focused on thank you prime
minister one follow-up question
different topic we do not currently have
a member of parliament a member of
parliament in this region in cabinet
with the departure of bartis jagger from
cabinet recently is uh
why is that and will your government
rectify that important area and we've
had cabinet membership for many years we
continue to have an amazing team of
strong mps and ministers from across the
country who are focused on this region
on the growing
challenges and opportunities in southern
ontario and i can assure you
that all of us do a great job making
sure we're speaking to and for all
canadians but as always we're looking at
to grow the teams in coming elections
and we're going to continue to stay
connected with canadians and build the
kind of team that is responsive to what
canadians need next question
good morning prime minister liam casey
with the canadian press um major group
of uh major group helping veterans um
transition network to get interpreters
out of afghanistan they're winding down
operations
you know because they say there's
bureaucratic cubes that are blocking
efforts to get paperwork and causing
this bottleneck
what do you have to say to the
interpreters who risked their lives to
help canada and now feel
abandoned by your government the
situation in afghanistan is
heartbreaking
the
taking over that country by the taliban
has made it unbelievably difficult
not just for canadians who served and
sacrificed to build a better future for
afghans but also to people who want to
welcome people who've supported them
to canada we have
accepted and been able to uh draw to
canada well over 10 000
people fleeing afghanistan we are on our
way to 40 000. the challenges we are
facing however are very much linked to
the difficulty of actually processing
people from within afghanistan because
as might be imagined the taliban are not
exactly being helpful in terms of
bringing people out of afghanistan to
canada we continue to work with partners
in the region and with allies around the
world because we remain committed to
welcoming over 40 000 afghan
refugees translators people who've
worked with canadians
human rights defenders
while at the same time we continue to be
committed to humanitarian support within
afghanistan to make sure that
opportunities continue to be there for
people who remain
thank you
another topic there have been several
attacks of late in and around mosques
the imam of
dar al tahit
in mississauga where there was a man
with an axe and unleashed bear spray
they say the federal government's
dragging their feet on the federal
security infrastructure program that
would help them
you know beef up security they're
wondering when that money
will be coming
so that they can get things in security
guards and
surveillance equipment to help their
members
over
over the past number of years we have
continued to invest in the community
infrastructure program for
mosques and synagogues and and
vulnerable community centers and we will
continue to be there with supports
but it's a really big shame that we have
to
canada shouldn't be a place where we
have to worry about
fences and armed guards and video
cameras and security systems
in places of worship
canada is one of those countries that
does diversity and inclusivity better
than just about any other country in the
world
but over the past years we've seen a
rise
in hate crimes
a rise in intolerance
and racist acts
part of it is the pandemic sure
and the and the stress and the anxiety
that comes from that
but a part of it is a trend
towards greater polarization in our
politics greater intolerance
in our communities
that the vast vast majority of canadians
stand against
islamophobia
anti-semitism anti-black racism
anti-lgbt
all the all the discriminations
that we see on the rise anti-asian
racism through through the pandemic
are absolutely unacceptable
and as a government and quite frankly as
canadians
we will continue to stand together with
vulnerable communities
and demonstrate that there is no place
for hatred and hateful acts
in canada whether
in real life or online and we're going
to continue
to move forward to make sure that all
canadians are safe and i look forward to
sitting down with the muslim community
here in the kitchener-waterloo region
later this afternoon to talk about the
amazing things they're doing
to contribute to the community while
they celebrate the holy month of ramadan
last question please
thank you hello mr prime minister uh my
question has to do again with housing i
was looking at the rapid housing
investments we have 1.5 billion dollars
over two years and a quarter of that
going to
women-focused programming but there are
still concerns regarding a lack of
targeted investment specifically for
indigenous people that we know are
disproportionately impacted by housing
and security what's your government
doing to ensure that marginalized
communities and indigenous individuals
aren't overlooked by these new housing
investments
from the very beginning of
canada's first ever national housing
strategy that we put forward in in 2017
which at that point was 40 billion
dollars is now up to about 72 billion
dollars investments in housing there
were specific targets and carveouts for
indigenous canadians uh for for women
for vulnerable communities for canadians
with disabilities these are the kinds of
things that we've built into the
programs we have and even as we move
forward on the rapid housing initiative
as we move forward on partnerships
with with municipalities there are
specific supports for the most
vulnerable
there are often women and young families
fleeing domestic violence
marginalized canadians who don't have
the same access to credit i think of
black canadians and others
where systemic racism continues to be a
challenge so we are explicit about
making sure that there is a focus on
those communities and we will continue
to it is extremely important that we be
there uh to ensure that everyone uh can
benefit from this and leaning in on
canadians facing greater barriers is uh
core to it i can also say that we have
specific urban sorry urban indigenous
and indigenous housing programs uh to
the tunes of billions of dollars that
we've put forward in this budget as a
government we will continue to
specifically work with uh indigenous
communities to build a path forward on
reconciliation that brings everyone
along
my follow-up is just regarding the uh
foreign buyer ban the two-year ban uh
there has already been criticism levy
that there may still be loopholes
regarding um ways to work around the
restrictions that are even put in place
by this budget um what's your government
doing to make sure that you're able to
address those loopholes quickly as
opposed to just you know where there's
opportunity people are going to try and
find ways to exploit it
we are very aware as we move forward
with strong measures to protect
canadians there are going to be people
trying to get around them whether it was
our measures to bring in better tax
fairness by lowering taxes for the
middle class and raising them on the
wealthiest one percent uh whether it's
measures to support people through the
pandemic unfortunately there are always
going to be people trying to find ways
around it that's why in the design work
on the
on the foreign buyers ban uh that we
will be bringing in we're going to make
sure that it applies as broadly and as
as completely as possible because uh we
don't we need to actually address this
problem and we don't need people getting
around it thank you that concludes
today's press conference